put up or shut up that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
it's clickbait and it's the left's go-to
shiny object for keeping African
Americans on the line well of course I'm
talking about reparations and San
Francisco's latest over-the-top
proposals most of which will never see
the light of day
now in what's a purported effort to
level the playing field after slavery
and discrimination
111 recommendations were proposed to
advance the reparations agenda and on
the list check this out a five million
dollar payment to every eligible
African-American adult
debt forgiveness Lord knows how much
that's going to be guaranteed income of
ninety seven thousand dollars a year for
250 years and homes in San Francisco for
just one dollar per family but don't
worry
if they're HOA or parking fees that come
with the housing those would be covered
as well
now the Hoover institution is putting
the price tag on just the five million
dollar per person part of the plan
at six hundred thousand dollars per
household
now imagine adding that massive burden
onto families already dealing with the
crushing weight of Biden inflation
that's hard to fathom
but fans of reparations want to suck you
into the debate in order to stereotype
all of you as unfeeling uncaring jerks
you have been struck by the overheated
and irrational response to this draft
report those of my constituents who lost
their minds about this proposal it's not
something we're doing or we would do for
other people it's something we would do
for our future for our collect
everybody's Collective the future and
the generations to come
wow it would benefit our Collective
futures
how could anyone be against that
now reaching into your wallet to
apologize for slavery is the least you
people could do
well and of course Money Talks Justin
Hansford a law professor at Howard
University put it this way if you're
going to try to say you're sorry well
you have to speak in the language that
people understand and money is that
language
recall that this debate began on college
campuses decades ago and then the idea
really gained Traction in recent years
especially after the death of George
Floyd
and now even African-Americans who've
enjoyed huge success in America they
think they deserve cash
individual white people are saying I
didn't do it and and my ancestors didn't
even do it and and you're and you were
not your ancestors that's that's I'm a
descendant of those of those answers I
know but Hey listen when a debt is older
debt is old period but you've got a lot
of money so you say you should get more
yes I'm not I'm 97 a West African born
in Charleston South Carolina so I should
I should definitely get a check
and it's about much more though than
assigning Collective guilt and assigning
penalties on people who never enslaved
anyone
reparations are also needed we're told
to stop the crime wave there's only one
thing that would stop our children from
busting into these liquor stores and
grocery stores stealing junk food and
and still in different things and that's
reparations there's only one thing that
would stop our kids from busting into
these jewelry stores stealing watches
and jury and that's reparations
now at this point California Democrats
well let's face it they're desperate the
state is collapsing in crime there's a
huge Exodus out of the state of course
we've all seen the homelessness the drug
abuse and the despair
if you're a minority with a Chance of
opening let's say a small business in
Dallas or in San Francisco
why on Earth would you choose San
Francisco
now the lunatrons On The Board of
Supervisors may not be able to
revitalize the economy there but they
will try to entice you with a grab bag
of goodies
and whatever you do do not get bogged
down on the cost of reparations
so a lot of people are stuck on numbers
if you want to look at numbers look at
the birth rate of African Americans
look at the incarceration rate of
African Americans look at the dropout
rate of African Americans look at the
graduation rate of African Americans
but even renowned supporters of
reparations are scratching their heads
with how the San Francisco fruitcakes
arrived at that five million dollar per
person number
I don't believe that there's been any
serious explanation as to how the San
Francisco task force came up with that
number when people hear that figure it
sounds extraordinarily large it's not
consistent with the uh the ways in which
uh Kirsten Mullen and I have attempted
to calculate it
well he's right and by the way Gavin
Newsom he might be wrong on most issues
but he's not a complete he knows
this issue would be a political
nightmare and it could be the straw that
breaks the donkeys back in California
and by the way plenty of Rich Suburban
white liberals they have no interest hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else